[Music]
welcome Ben Frankel I'm a product
manager for Google Play and with me
today I will be joined by Jonathan Chang
Steve supe as well as Andrew Giuliano
and today we're going to be talking
about unleashing the power of Play Store
discovery and what I wanted to do first
always get to know the audience a little
better I don't know all of you I know
some of you I don't know all of you and
what I wanted to do is to see like what
kind of the mix of people are here today
so I want to see is so a show of hands
how many of you are on the business side
of games you know the product managers
and so forth all right got a decent
representation there how many of you
used to play console regularly either
looking at reports alright there's even
more hands and how many of you are
engineers how many of you write code at
least sometimes or have ever written
code that might need some more hands all
right well this is a great mix for this
talk because we have something for
everybody today so for the business side
of the house we're gonna be talking
about business impacts what these tools
can do for your business we're gonna
show some case studies for the Play
console folks we're gonna show you how
to use the tools we're gonna be talking
about today and for the engineers in the
row we have an entire section at the end
that's a technical deep dive into how to
use Google Play instant and it even
involves actual code oops I kind of blew
that one all right so there's one more
question one more exciting question I
kind of spoil the result but just bear
with me
humor me for a second I want to see one
more show of hands one more show of
hands how many of you think you've
either seen or yourself have taken full
advantage of all the promotional tools
that playe offers okay so we got a
couple of very optimistic people here
and I love that about you
but the answer is like no none of you
have really been able to take advantage
of all of the tools that play provides
to promote your game on the store but
it's not your fault it's not you it's
it's
or us I should say because we haven't
really done a good job of showing you
showing you what it would look like if
you used all of the tools at your
disposal to their full extent possible
and today we're going to close that gap
with an example with an example led by a
good friend of mine Bert this is Bert
and through Bert's
eyes and some of his friends which I'll
also introduce to you will show you what
it would look like if you turned all the
plays promotional tools up to eleven
more than ten up to eleven this is a
really big deal so why don't we get
things start we're gonna start at the
beginning of Bert's journey on the Play
Store so Bert's the type of person who
always wants to know what's coming next
he loves watching trailers upcoming
movies and he gets the same buzz when
he's looking at the pre-reg section on
the store so Bert's looking at the
period section of the store and he spots
one of his favorite franchises this game
snore craft is big on PC and unaware
that things could get even more exciting
Bert dives into the store listing wait
what's that he thinks there's free stuff
too I can unlock exclusive rewards just
by pre-registering and there's a demo I
can actually play this game right now I
can preserve and reserve my avatars name
I can customize my avatar and I can earn
experience points all the way up to
launch this indeed was a triumphant day
for Bert bursting with excitement
Bert pre-registered for snore crafts and
shared the pre-reg listing with all of
his friends or almost all of his friends
Bert's slept well that night dreaming of
the rewards he was soon to receive fast
forward and its launch day Bert wakes up
stretches and sees a notification that
snore craft is now available to
everybody
and before even getting out of bed bed
Burt installed snore craft and
immediately redeemed the long-awaited
reward boy was bird excited but this was
not just a good day for Burt
this was also a good day for all the
people
Burt invited to the pre-registration and
not only his friends but their friends
and then their friends friends and so on
and so forth until almost all of Burt's
friends were playing snore craft almost
almost everyone except for the Bob's who
I'm also introducing for the first time
here today to all of you so it's a bit
of background on the Burt's these are
identical quadruplets that were
separated at Birth I know and and
through a mere quirk of fate they happen
to all be named Bob you know what are
the chances and it might not be obvious
at first glance but when the Bob smile
you can really see the family
resemblance here
so because the Bob's missed out on
pre-registration the Bob's rode to snore
craft was different from Burt's and
Byrd's friends each had to chart their
own path to eventually installing snore
craft so one Bob came through the new
and updated section another was
recommended snore craft the third Bob
came through the role-playing games
collection Bob number four had it
suggested through ads and for good
measure their cousin Becky discovered
snore craft through the editors choice
section but they all eventually landed
on the store listing but before we go on
I wanted to provide a bit of additional
context about the Bob's so after they
were separated at birth each ended up
growing up in a different country one
lives in Portugal
one in Brazil one in Mexico and one
lived here in the US and each of them
independently developed an unyielding
passion for soccer or how almost
everyone else in the world refers to it
as football and this context is
important because not only to each of
the Bob's
find their own way to the store listing
but when they arrived at the store
listing they discovered it was
customized to their preferences so with
an international football event looming
the Bob from Portugal arrived on a store
listing that celebrated his national
team the game icon two screenshots the
texts all show their support for the
team he loves the Bob from Brazil saw
store listing that celebrated his team
and the Bob's from Mexico and the Bob
from the US store saw store listings
that celebrated their national team's -
and the Bob's from Portugal in Brazil
immediately installed the game right off
the bat no questions asked
however the bombs from Mexico and the US
were initially a little reluctant to
install the game right away one Bob was
concerned about the available space on
his device the other bob was new to
gaming and just wasn't familiar with the
franchise but fortunately snore craft
had an instant game the space can drain
Bob was relieved that he could try the
game before committing to a big install
and the new be well though he was
unfamiliar with the franchise his
curiosity got the better of him and he
clicked to try now to eventually all the
Bob's installed the game and played
happily ever after the end
[Applause]
so hopefully that's given you a sense of
what taking full advantage of all the
marketing tools the Play Store has to
offer looks like from a user's
perspective so through bird size you've
seen the power of place pre launch tools
the viral growth opportunity the impact
of pre-reg rewards and Google Play
instant and through the eyes of all the
Bob's and Becky you saw the impact of
place post launch marketing tools from
customized store listings to stroe
listing experiments so what we're gonna
do now is we're gonna turn our attention
to what's the business impact is of
these tools and the technical details of
how to use them and so when I hand
things off to Jonathan in a second who's
going to be talking about the pre-launch
marketing tools then I'm going to he's
gonna hand to Steve who's gonna be
talking about the post launch marketing
tools and then lastly for the engineers
in the room andrew is going to do a deep
dive into how to build an instant game
with that come on on Jonathan take it
away
thanks Ben in the next section we're
gonna go over some of the some time to
go over some of the tools from the
debater suspected will show and explain
the opportunities available for you to
use today and go over some best
practices to make your pre-launch
campaigns as exciting as possible let's
start with pre-launch as we all know in
the console and PC world pre-launch
marketing and even pre-ordering has
become a norm well today I'm excited to
say that pre-launch marketing is also
increasingly popular for mobile games in
fact for most games the pre-launch and
launch period is typically the time when
you have the most buzz and interest
around your game many game developers
have told us that during this period is
also the cheapest time to acquire a new
user throughout the lifetime of their
games as such it's crucial to engage
with your potential players and
hopefully capture the interest in your
game before you launch so how do you
make the most of this important period
in your games life cycle and how do you
effectively communicate what is special
about your game and capture player
interest even before you launch luckily
we at Google Play have some tools which
can help you to grasp this unique
pre-launch opportunity until recently it
has been very difficult for developers
on play to capture pre-launch buzz
around their games and translate this to
actual installs at launch developers had
to think very hard about where to spend
their marketing dollars and how to
invest in different efforts as there is
no easy way to capture this interest and
maintain it until the game is ready well
today I'm pleased to announce that
Googlers placed pre-registration feature
has is available to all developers on
Google Play for those of you aren't
familiar with the tool pre-registration
helps capture demand generated by
pre-launch marketing and it activates a
launch to help accelerate your
pre-launch success in the market when
your pre-registration campaign is
started a clear pre-registration quota
action will appear on your pre-release
door page which allows users to register
interest in your title in return for
pre-registering
players will receive a launch day
notification from Google Play allowing
them to become one of the first to
install and play your game not only does
it allow you to engage and reward core
fans early but pre-registration
notifications also drive higher volumes
of D 1 and D 7 installs on top of this
Claes pre-registration tool is more
effective than most when it comes to
driving conversions to install on
average we actually see the place for
registration feature sees about a thirty
eight percent conversion to install
which is a much higher conversion rate
versus other pre-registration sources
finally pre-registration has the added
benefit of allowing you to display your
store listing to use this on play even
before you launch this allows you to
drive traffic from all your marketing
sources their single destination in
order to capture launch demand for your
title next setting up a pre-registration
campaign is super easy using the Play
console first you want to navigate to a
produces then you'll need to upload an
apk or bundle containing a manifest
describing your device types you want to
include in your campaign and release it
on to one of your closed testing tracks
remember you don't need to make this
close testing track available to any of
your users its purpose can be simply to
hold your apk or bundle contain
these device restrictions this will in
turn activate the pre-registration
control center which will allow you to
turn off and on countries where you want
to run your pre-registration campaigns
in in this control center you can also
see pre-registration signups per country
as well as conversions to install per
country when you eventually launch your
game note that we will be limiting
pre-registration campaigns to run for a
maximum of 90 days in each country you
will see a helpful indicator in the
console telling you when you are close
to this time finally I want to go over
some recommendations to consider when
using pre-registration with Google Play
first allow some time to build
excitement in your title usually between
3 to 12 weeks is ideal next use all your
channels to indicate and build interest
around your title you can use media
social YouTube communities with your own
website etc and drive your Android
traffic to place pre-registration on the
Play Store specifically due to the
higher conversion rates
so that's place pre-registration feature
in a nutshell but wait there's more
today I am pleased to announce that we
are launching pre-registration rewards
to all developers what does this
actually allow you to do
pre-registration rewards allows you to
offer a free ia p or in-app purchase to
all your players who have pre-registered
for your title this reward is get as
delivered to users via play and is
advertised by a special card on your
store listing as you can see on the
screen configuring this reward is also
very easy using play console you want to
select the IEP you want to give away
supply the text that users will see on
your store listing about the ia P and
when your game launches this I in a user
library for you to
consume in your full game experience
also remember to configure a reward
before starting your pre-registration
campaign ensure that all your users will
receive your reward when you launch
using pre-registration rewards is a
great way to add value to your
pre-registration campaign not only does
it help incentivize users to
pre-register for your game
it also can drive up lifts of
conversions to install as there's value
waiting for the player when they install
and play your game in our pilots we have
actually seen about a 15% increase in
conversions when games are using rewards
in fact we didn't just see an increase
in conversion one of our developers
Nexon in South Korea also shared data
showing they stole a sizeable increase
in uplift uplift and engagement for
users who received a reward versus those
who didn't players were more likely to
stick with the game and continue
actively playing if they received a
reward at the start
pre-registration rewards is available to
all developers right now to use in the
Google Play console so another new
addition to pre-registration is the
ability to run an instant game alongside
your pre-registration campaign instant
games allow you to highlight key
gameplay elements of your game and can
even display a clear court action to
pre-register from within the game itself
upload and configure your instant game
as known in the play console and it will
now show up during pre-registration if
we distribute it to the same countries
as you are running your campaigns in
this is yet another way to add value to
be pre-registration campaign and make it
more enticing and encourage players to
finally pre-register for your game it's
also important to call out that all the
features we just described can be used
in conjunction with each other
to help create a unique and compelling
pre-launch marketing story for instance
you may want to consider tying a
pre-registration reward around the key
item or character you are showing
prominently in your marketing material
tailor your store listing around your
pre-registration reward or instant game
and you may even allow place to sign up
and create a character inside your
instant game which they can then carry
over into your full game when it
launches we believe the intelligent
usage of these features can help
highlight and communicate what is
special about your game even before the
audience gets their hands on the
finished product and we hope you feel
inspired to create innovative and play
for pre-launch campaigns now I'm going
to hand over to Steve who's going to
talk about how to effectively market
your games even after you launch hi
everyone my name's Steve I'm a product
manager on the Play console thanks very
much for coming today
right so at this point Jonathan's just
walked you through running a successful
pre-registration campaign and you've
done all this work getting ready for
launch
but once you've launched I'm sorry to
tell you you're not actually finished
you've now just opened up the floodgates
your game is now exposed to the vast
demand that Google Play brings to you
this is scary but it's a good thing but
you have to keep optimizing your
marketing message if you're going to
make the most of this exposure so I'm
going to walk you through the key
features that will help you to do that
so that you can continuously improve
your marketing and your acquisition rate
over the life of your launch so when you
first launch your game on Google Play
you'll have to design and publish your
store listing the store listing is your
front page for your users
it's where users read what you have to
say about your game and where they can
browse your screenshots your trailer
videos
and hopefully even try an instant game
you've probably spent weeks or even
months agonizing over the perfect icon
screenshots and more to go on this page
and I'm sure your teams did a great job
but the thing is it's really really hard
to know if you've gotten this right even
if you think you're getting a good
conversion rate how do you really know
that you've optimized there's a lot of
people out there visiting your page and
you'll want to maximize your chance of
convincing them to install and that's
why the Google Play console provides
store listing experiments store listing
experiments is our a/b testing framework
to let you try variants of your store
listing via properly controlled
experiments you can easily try new
screenshots videos and descriptions so
that you can try all the great and maybe
not so great ideas that you've ever had
you provide the ideas we provide
statistical analysis so that you can be
sure that the changes in the results are
significant you'll find store listing
experiments underneath store presence on
the left-hand nav
for those of you that are already using
them we've introduced two new metrics
that we think are your gold star metrics
when you're launching a game first we
have first-time installers these are
users who have visited your listing and
are installing your game for the first
time the other Numan metric is one day
retention which are first-time
installers who have not uninstalled your
game in the first day so they've
continued to keep your game more than 24
hours which is when we find is the key
time for retention even cooler
both of these metrics are now reported
in hourly intervals so previously you
might have had the wait 24 hours or more
in order to see the most current results
so now you can see them every hour you
can also opt in to receive email
notifications for when we think your
experiment is complete this will help
you to make decisions more quickly so
you could take advantage of good changes
and avoid the bad ones as quickly as
possible
using store listing experiments can lead
to great gains and user acquisition such
as hothead games we saw a 40% increase
in acquisition rate simply by improving
their icon here are some tips and tricks
that you should keep in mind when you're
making the most out of these store
listing experiments so first of all you
should think back to how you were taught
experimentation in high school science
class to get the clearest results you
should test just a single asset at a
time for example changing your ads your
icon or maybe a screen shot because if
you change too many things at once you
won't actually know what drove that
change in acquisition right second
you'll want to make sure that you test
for at least a full week so that you can
track weekday and weekend performance
because users behave differently
depending on the time of the week for
games the most prominent assets are your
icon screenshots and videos so make sure
to prioritize these for testing finally
when you have a variant that we tell you
is working you'll want to promote that
one to be your main listing as soon as
possible but you should continue serving
your original has a 1% experiment for a
few more weeks so that you can ensure
that over time this new one is still
outperforming your old one great so once
you've optimized your store listing you
now have a solid foundation for user
acquisition you've probably learned a
lot about your users along the way and
the best ways to communicate what's
unique and exciting about your game but
as you're looking at your experiment
results and diving deeper into our user
acquisition reports you may find that
there are specific segments that aren't
converting as well as you'd like
Google Play enables you to run this
global business and not all users are
the same so I'm excited to talk to you
about a powerful new feature that allows
you to market to these different user
segments in a way that it's much more
likely to get them too installing again
this is what we call custom store
listings custom store listings allow you
to create unique store listings
delivered to specific user segments so
you tell us which types of users should
this listing and we do the rest so let
me walk you through some of the new
targeting criteria the first targeting
dimension that we've introduced is
country up until now you've had to rely
on language as a rough proxy for
geography but users in different
countries don't always choose the
language you would guess for example did
you know that half of users in India
over half of users in India have set
their device language to either American
or British English and these flavours of
language are not the same I know this
firsthand so I'm an American born and
raised but I live in London and if
you've ever been to London if you ever
find yourself invited to a fancy dress
party you want to make sure that you got
the country right because if you get it
wrong you could end up wearing a tuxedo
to a costume party or worse show up
wearing a costume to something like a
wedding or an anniversary or something
worse who knows so with this feature you
can serve up to five different listings
two completely different groups of
countries so by first targeting by
geography you're very specific and how
you communicate to your users so imagine
you're a football game sorry a soccer
game but do you want your do you want
your users to be dreaming of being in
the most successful squad or do you want
them to be part of the winningest team
in the tables you can also use your icon
to help users feel more at home such as
the use of English and American flags in
the icons we have here we're also adding
other targeting capabilities you can now
target on the launch date of your game
for those of you that are excited about
pre-reg this is a really powerful way to
change your marketing message to the
right set of users throughout the
lifecycle of your game so for example
through pre-registration users you can
now highlight rewards or display a
pre-launch teaser trailer that the user
is in places where you've launched are
not seeing so you can really customize
your message for example game builds
game italia
was able to make use of three
registration store listings so like most
games they didn't launch everywhere
using this feature they were able to
communicate their launched only to the
users that were eligible for it and the
increase they basically doubled their
pre-registration conversion rate finally
taking a step back I want to give you a
peek behind the curtain of what else
were up to we're launching an early
access program for install state today
when you think about your store listing
you're thinking about how do I get users
to install the game but some of these
visitors already have your game
installed or worse they've turned or
maybe uninstalled your game so we can
help you to re-engage with these users
such as in this example but we can
communicate new gameplay in order to
bring these users back and excite them
into reinstalling your game if you're
interested in being part of this beta
that we're running be sure to go to gqo
/ play / install States EAP and we'll
get you signed up all right so I've just
got a lot of time talking to you about
the marketing message that you provide
but there are other parts of the store
listing that users see specifically I'm
talking about ratings did you know that
42% of users believe a one-star review
mentioned stability or bugs no one in
this room means to have stability
problems but it's often hard to measure
and track them so that you can fix them
luckily we have Android vitals to help
you gather more insight we offer 15
engineering metrics across five
different performance areas so represent
the things that users care about the
most so you can measure the performance
and quality of your app has experienced
on real devices in the hands of real
users in the real world so if you're
interested in android vitals be sure to
join some of these other talks that are
going on this week so to wrap it all up
custom store listings for countries and
pre-registration is available today as
those are the store listing experiments
for all of these store listings I hope
I've inspired you to think about cool
and unusual ways that you might be able
to segment your audience to really
squeeze out as much of the acquisition
rate as you possibly can now andrew is
going to come up on stage
and walk you through building an instant
game which is a very important
part of any store listing that requires
a little bit more technical know-how
thanks for your time thanks Steve hello
my name is Andrew Giuliano and today I
will be talking to you about Google Play
instant and to answer your question yes
I got a really bad sunburn during the
keynote this morning it happens it
happens to the best of us Google Play
incident is a technology that enables
users to instantly be immersed in your
experience with a single tap letting
them try your game without the weight of
install here we see an example of cookie
jam blast being launched from the China
button in the Play Store today instant
games can be launched from anywhere
across all of plays properties and
beyond now how does Google Play instant
help your game simply put it is getting
players into your experience fast it's
increasing discoverability you're
getting more players into your
experience across too many surfaces
you're driving installs players are
given the opportunity to install your
game without ever having to leave the
experience and you're improving
retention by offering players that taste
your game Google Play and helps players
feel more confident that your game is
worth installing and this could lead to
less players uninstalling after your
download and as you can see this
technology has been helpful to our
partners across different categories
monetization strategies technologies
we've seen instant be impactful and
driving uplift for our developers if
there's one key takeaway from this line
it's that instant could be helpful for
your game I also want to call out our
fantastic ecosystem of developers that
has formed to help others create their
own instant games in fact upon board
just yesterday released their app on
board studio tools specifically built
for instant games which helps creators
create an instigated no code I believe
this is a testament that we are not
alone and seeing the potential Vincey
games to help developers drive installs
and we're not stopping there we will be
continuing to expand the reach of
instant you may have noticed a few
slides ago the games playlist that
you try a lot of games very fast that's
on the far left and our success hasn't
bolded us to elevate instant games from
the store listening to the top layer of
Play Store discovery from search game
search page to game highlights and
collections on the landing page these
new experiences were made possible
through the incredible support of our
partners billing instant games okay
so now that we've seen the impact of
instant we will do deep dive I'm
building your own instant game from
scratch engineers for the room this pit
will be for you now under the hood and
instigate is just a 10 megabyte or less
apk that is being served over play
downloaded and run on a more secure
runtime on the device creating a
separate apk and getting under that size
limit it might sound difficult but here
we will show you how easy is to create
your own into game and will give you all
the tools to do so in fact if anything
is to be taken away from the next
section it's at creating instant games
it's now easier than ever in this
example we'll use unity but nearly any
apk can be made instant and we have a
great plugin for Coco's creators
developers we'll see that later now
first off there are four major steps in
creating instant game and this fans any
game engine you're going to build it out
so you're gonna actually make the apk
instant you're gonna gracefully convert
your users from the instant game to the
installed game you're gonna reduce size
to meet that 10 megabyte requirement and
we'll give you some tics and tips and
tricks to do that and you're gonna do
some publishing and testing on play to
test the distribution of your instant
game so let's build the instant game so
first off the tools will need unity the
great Google Play instant plugin for
unity that will make a lot of this
easier you can get down the asset store
you can also download it on github an
Android device can be physical of ritual
we recommend testing on pre Oreo and
Oreo Plus devices just because there's a
slight difference in the runtime and
access your source code and Play
Developer console okay
so first step you will go to the build
settings and the plug-in you will choose
the scenes that you'd like to include in
your instant game and that's it so the
URL is not required we provide a default
one anywho
and don't worry about asset bundles
we'll see that a little later next
you'll configure your player settings
this is a mix of required changes you
need to make your game instant it's all
a click of a button you just click
update as well as some recommended
changes to help reduce that size and
then you just select build and run from
the plug-in and you can run your game
instantly locally super easy so now that
we've built an into game let's
gracefully convert those users from the
instant game to install game because
obviously that's what we're trying to do
here right that's the scope so we make
it easy by providing a show install
prompt where you just call one line of
code we show the prompt and we take care
of the rest
and it works for pre-reg as well so
players can pre-register and install
without ever having to leave the instant
experience you know likely you should
put this at the end of your experience
right and of a level a match and you
could also show a persistent button so
the user could at any time go to install
additionally you might want to carry
some information over I'll show you that
too that could be by in-game items
levels you know when you customize your
character you can use a cookie API to
transfer the state over so here you'll
just call the one line above and we will
do the rest
likewise you can just put a string of
data together and we will bring that
over to the installed game and this is
all you have to call to get that data on
the other side and just like that you
have all the tools to convert your user
from instant to install ok let's look at
reducing size this could be the most
frightening one for some developers but
we'll give you some help so first off
you want to narrow the scope of the
content your instant game you don't want
to include your full game as an instant
game and if it's under ten megabytes
already that's great but really you want
to offer a trailer of your game you want
to offer the most exciting pieces you
know show gameplay that is critical to
understanding the full game but you
shouldn't just choose the easy levels
show the exciting ones as well and again
games as large as three hundred fifty
megabytes have been able to launch
instant games and I'm sure more even
larger than that no matter what game you
have you can create an instant game
remove unnecessary assets do deep-dive
to your technical resources remove
what's not needed I needed assets even
reducing resolution really should ask
yourself is it critical to get a
teaching experience if not remove it
also follow those recommended settings
I've showed earlier that really helps in
reducing size okay
finally a really good way to get into
that size limit our asset bundles they
allow you to load assets dynamically
where the Odinson game is running and
these assets will not count against your
limit while you may use as many as a
bundles as you like each asset level
must be less than 50 megabytes in size
so be thoughtful on how many asset
models you import there are three pieces
needed to use decimals in your instant
game first you want to create asset
models from the scenes in your game you
want to show user from your loading
screen while that is loading up and you
will need a web server CDN to serve
these asset bundles and using the tool
in the plugin we will help help you take
care of this for soon so first you'll go
to the bundle creation tab and you'll
select the scenes that you want to
include in the asset bundle once
finished we will give you a file that
you'll throw up on your web server or
CDN and in that next screen you'll
specify the URL to access those files
additionally you can provide a custom
background for the loading screen I was
talking about earlier but we provide a
default one as well so super easy and
just like that
when you click finish we will generate
the code to retrieve the asset bundles
in your game so it's really easy and
you're all set okay so we've looked at
some tools for reducing size let's look
at play and how play can help in this
testing of in the development phase so
you should take your instant game and
you should upload it to your internal
test track there's no size limit here so
you can use this internally while you're
building this instant game to test the
distribution up to a hundred users that
you'll choose manually now make sure
that there is an accompanying
installable listing the or in pre reg
phase because you need to upgrade to
installed or you need to you know be in
the pre reg phase and then of course
push to production when you're ready and
just like that you have all the tools to
make a production ready
again you can see more information below
at the link not using unity no problem
make the following changes in your
manifest to make nearly any apk locally
rentable is instant and of course you'll
need to follow the four key steps we
talked about some api's earlier if you
follow the github link you'll see some
sample code and native android for using
the same API it's like cookie di and a
show install prompt
we also offer plugin with cocoa Strader
that allows you to create an instigated
by recording the gameplay and I'll show
you the assets needed to package in with
your instant game it's a really cool
experience so to quickly recap there are
three key things I want you to walk away
with number one that offer that play
offers an incredible array of
promotional and marketing tools from
pre-reg to store listing experiments to
Google plants in to these tools are easy
to use most are configurable through the
play console and in the case of Google
Play instant we showed you you could
build a demo yourself or have one of our
implementation partners build one for
you lastly plays promotional capab
capabilities can deliver material
business impact so what's next you can
start by taking a picture of this slide
which includes all the links from the
presentations phones are going up now
that we've taken a look at what instant
games are how they can help and how to
build your own I want to give you a
chance to test some of the instant games
that are out there today scan the QR
code and you'll be brought to a
collection of gradients and games on the
Play Store at the bottom here's the link
to sign up for the customized store
listing features install say EAP as well
so with that
thank you for your time enjoy this
evening
[Music]